minable mais bon on prend le crip à
casimir une pépite entendre son va-tout
et déjà vous avez vu comme il est parti
va effectivement ce pauvre monsieur
roberto n'osera plus venir monter ses
coûts sur l'île aux enfants
quand je pense qu'il voulait nous faire
tiquer lille pour prendre nos places
heureusement que vous l'avez fait peur
avec votre calme mais je dois avouer que
c'est mieux que c'est surtout toi qui
l'a effrayé avec ses fausses dents et
c'est au score je pense que je les
flanquer une sacrée frousse
monsieur jean à vous voulez bien revenir
je ne voudrais pas effrayé d'autres
personnes oh mais c'est un grand honneur
pour moi casimir que d'enlever les armes
de héros comme autant de la chevalerie
la maison voilà merci beaucoup monsieur
duchesneau or ce n'est rien à casimir
mais tu vois bien que nous n'ayons pas
les mêmes idées tous les deux j'ai pour
toi une affection sincère et tu me
trouveras toujours à tes côtés pour
défendre l'île aux enfants
c'est très émouvant ce que vous me dites
monsieur du chemin vous me donnez envie
de pleurer les biens retient toac et
généraux ne pleure pas d'ailleurs que je
m'en aille j'ai un rendez vous urgent
avec des personnalités non mais je vous
comprends bien au revoir monsieur du
snow allait casimir goodbye pardon mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous m'insultez à
mais je ne t'insulte pas casimir je te
dis au revoir un objet ça se dit bout de
bâle
ah oui voilà allez au revoir casimir
goodbye on voit un coup broussailles
gros ça il me suit du snob
or voilà françois et julie j'ai une idée
je vais leur faire croire que j'ai
accepté tous les projets de monsieur
rotor pour moi il faut que je prenne
l'air triste
dans l'île aux enfants c'est pas tous
les jours le printemps là
alalalala d'enfants soit quasi muet
transforme la 500 lits et tu as vu
sourire tragique
c'est leur pays sinistre des monstres
malraux le tgv n'est raciste et donne le
caf
or excusez moi j'aimerais beaucoup
chanté avec gaieté et bonne humeur mais
je n'y arrive pas il ya des jours où la
vie est vraiment triste
oui mais avec des thés bonne humeur
c'est pas très réussie n'est pas eu du
gaz où on fait voyons ne fait pas cette
tête d'enterrement tu cherche à nous
faire pleurer non non je cherche à
retrouver ma bonne humeur en chantant
engage des membres alors comment toi
casimir récupéreront le moral allez
expliquer ce qui ne va pas
ô toi que juni tu as fait une nouvelle
énorme bêtise in de plus ça n'est pas
grave
ne te pardonne on avance moins bien hier
pendant que je gardais le jardin j'ai
fait la connaissance d'un personnage
étrange à l'air mystérieux au les
mystères j'adore faire
que voulez vous c'est bien il a évolué à
porter une idée géniale pour changer la
vie dans l'île aux enfants et quelle est
cette idée à ce n'est pas facile à
expliquer et si tu ne nous met l'eau à
la bouche
ainsi c'est une idée qui pourrait rendre
les enfants beaucoup plus heureux et
bien dis là nous nous verrons bien
bon mais je ne peux pas pourquoi mais
parce que il m'a promis
il faudrait que vont que vous
l'acceptiez sans la connaître
accepter son idée sans la connaître ou
c'est bien compliqué tout ça
françois accepte toujours comme ça nous
verrons qu'est ce que c'est et bien
d'accord casimir l'idée générale est
acceptée bon alors vous me promettez de
faire ce que je vous demanderais oui
mais raconte nous vite maintenant
alors ce monsieur s'est d'abord promené
dans le jardin et il m'a dit c'est très
agréable ici à ça tout à fait d'accord
avec lui et ensuite il m'a dit on
également
malgré tout avec quelques changements on
pourrait rendre cette île beaucoup plus
agréable c'est vrai pourquoi pas on peut
certainement encore améliorer notre île
si c'est pour le bonheur des enfants on
peut toujours essayer
il s'est ensuite approché dans son
kiosque et il m'a dit le kiosque de
julie est très joli mais un peu démodé
et il ne paraît pas très solidaire je
laisse beaucoup comme sonic youth
à mon avis il est parfait surtout avec
toi dedans je lis des français gentil il
m'a dit que cantona ont proposé des
cloches toit en béton de 40 étages dont
avec six ascenseurs non feinte 40 étages
casimir tu te rends compte
je ne pourrai jamais rangé 40 et cache
tout seul non oui enfin je dois te dire
julie que donc dans ce kiosque tous
absolument tout sera automatique à aller
je vois par exemple pierre une sucette
il met une pièce dans un appareil il a
sa sucette tu sais ça le progrès oui je
comprends aussi nicole veut un verre de
grenadine a levé une pièce dans un autre
appareil et hop elle à son verre de
drogue oui c'est le programme animations
retors il y aura en tout 1500
distributeurs automatiques de 1500
distributeurs automatiques et pas de lui
bah oui oui mais vous avez accepté son
idée oui je crois que nous avons commis
une grosse erreur quand à toi françois
ans il te trouve très sympathique
harry a baissé c'est très aimable à lui
moi je suis très flatté jean-louis très
sympathique mais alors tout à fait
inutile au but d'exercer alors et
pourquoi le meeting bien il restera ici
une machine qui pourra conflit yb allons
à la seconde
rires moi j'en gonfle 1 en deux minutes
alors pas de françois non plus ou mal et
je les jeux qui les inventent rassis
françois n'est pas là mais ça pour les
jeux il y aura une autre machine
oui il faudra faire aux enfants 26 jeu
par jour 26 je suis encore battu moi je
ne retrouve que deux ou trois par
semaine et encore avec beaucoup de mal
je pense que nous ne sommes pas les
seules victimes de ce projet par
quittons annie plante il remplacer
monsieur 10 nab avait pour me fous de ce
mobile ne il ne compose remplacer non
non non il je trouve très décoratif pas
mais alors encore plus inutile que vous
de réunit le mieux en mieux et pour
notre droit facteurs alors la formidable
il m'apparaît d'une machine port plus
grande que ça qui a classé le courrier
le tri yellow distribué mm l'écrivait
évidemment julie si toutes ces machines
font mieux que nous si c'est pour le
bonheur des enfants et bien casimir se
décider nous partons mais moi moi j'en
porte mais ballot parce que m
les accès vitro avec plaisir ca
je prends mais beaucoup de bonbons aux
allées partons vite parce que si nous
réfléchissons trop long et bien
quasiment adieu mon oubli pas trop vite
quand toi julie revenez bondoné chaque
attaque qui at il encore que jamais mais
je ne veux pas que vous partiez ça
n'était qu'une seule fois mais presque
et c'est toi qui est inventé toute cette
histoire oh non non ce n'est pas moi
dont je n'aurais pas su réinventer tout
ça je me suis retour est réellement
revenus et y installer toutes ces
machines et nous chasser mais grâce à à
monsieur riche noble
nous avons chassé de lille bravo casimir
le progrès d'accord mais pas n'importe
quel oubli mais attendez vous ne
connaissez pas la meilleure car il
voulait que je parte aussi et c'est
encore une machine qui devrait remplacer
ce non non non non c'est lui qui voulait
me remplacer mais si les machines
peuvent nous remplacer ce personnage
aurait peut-être plus ou très bientôt
mais on s'était absolument impossible
impossible casimir ce monsieur retourne
me semble très intelligent oui il est
très intelligent mais il ne pouvait pas
me remplacer et qu'elle est il de si
épouvantables au il était il était
maigre maigre comme un canard
m